on fera ça quand on tombera les masques
une petite phrase signée emmanuel macron
lors de son déplacement dans une foire
agricole en provence le 10 septembre
dernier réformer les retraites oui mais
ce n'est pas encore le bon moment a
précisé le chef de l'état il faudra de
toute façon qu'on bouge après il ne faut
pas le faire tout de suite il faudra le
faire en écoutant tout le monde et puis
là on a d'autres priorités quand même il
faut qu'on soit intelligent
collectivement pour trouver le bon
système pour sauver nos retraites des
déclarations qui vont dans le sens de
celle de jean castex le 8 septembre le
premier ministre avait à l'issue d'un
séminaire gouvernemental expliqué que
les conditions n'étaient pas réunies
pour ouvrir le dossier de la réforme des
retraites à savoir une situation
sanitaire sous contrôle et une reprise
économique solide pas de grande réforme
donc a priori avant la fin du
quinquennat mais des bribes du projet
pourrait être tout de même mise en
oeuvre sous conditions c'est en tout cas
ce qu'a fait savoir le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriel attal de passage à
la fête de l'humanité ce samedi emmanuel
macron a acté que le projet vu le temps
qu'il reste d'ici la fin du quinquennat
ne pourrait pas être repris en l'état de
2019 il est cependant possible qu'il y
ait sur certaines parties du projet des
mesures qui soient prises d'ici la fin
du quinquennat un report de la réforme
qui a suscité certaines critiques
notamment à droite de l'échiquier
politique le président les républicains
du sénat gérard larcher a fustigé je
cite un abandon en rase campagne de la
réforme et ce qu'ils estiment être un
quinquennat pour presque rien en fait on
n'en fera rien ce sera d'ailleurs le
premier quinquennat depuis 2002 où il
n'y aura aucun élément sur la réforme
des retraites alors qu'elle est
indispensable si on veut sauver un des
points clés du système social
le système par répartition est
nécessaire pour retrouver une forme d'
équilibre financier pour les comptes
publics que nous avons peut-être oublié
mais qui s'imposera à nous à moins de
sept mois de la présidentielle reste à
savoir si l'exécutif osera s'engager sur
le chemin de cette réforme qui a
cristallisé
bien des tensions avant l'arrivée de la
crise sanitaire